for eleven weeks these roads had led to
nowhere blocked off cut off from the
rest of the world now people could make
their way out for the first time a city
finally reconnected to its country
nearly a hundred trains have sat idle
the whole while in the morning they
started moving again we were too excited
to fall asleep last night I was looking
forward to the lockdown being lifted
very much I set up an alert to remind
myself I was very happy some planes took
to the sky I haven't been out since
January the 21st this is the first time
I left the house today now I'm going
back home to meet my parents
do they miss you can you say and if
you're they sure they don't of course
don't speak to me anymore I'll start to
cry if you say more because it happens
so suddenly I didn't know I'd be stuck
here for so long Luhan is where it all
began the new coronavirus is thought to
have emerged from this wet market charts
when we reported here in January when
January the 23rd there were according to
the official statistics 571 cases and
just 17 deaths so when the order came to
lock down the city it was an
extraordinary measure 10 million people
quarantined the first time it had been
tried in modern medical history we made
it out just before the city was cut off
the no one knew if the lockdown would
work left alone the city and his people
suffered terribly thousands died his
medical resources were overwhelmed many
still feel anger and local officials for
their cover-up and for their
incompetence that reckoning will come
for now they're trying to get back to
normal life the lockdown is not fully
lifted restrictions are in place
everywhere they fear a second wave of
infection we suggest that only those who
need to resume work outside Wuhan should
leave but since the epidemic is not over
even though we lifted the city's MOC
down it doesn't mean we should stop
doing virus control or clear alerts
due to the TomTom but at this moment joy
conquered caution a spectacular light
show a celebration on a citywide scale
we now know their lock downs do they've
been put in place all around the world
and so the world will watch Lu Han again
to see how to see if you can lift a
lockdown safely
Tom Cheshire Sky News Dalian northeast
China